[Music]
you excited to catch some big fish
yeah well i'm looking forward to a
little you and me time man this is gonna
be awesome
[Music]
your destination is on the right
good morning okay cool
cool all right me and tom are here in
atlantic beach north carolina and i'm
here with captain jared with tombstone
charters and it's early in the morning
and we are headed out
for some big game fishing the world's
our oyster and we're excited to fish it
man
all right guys we went about an hour and
a half offshore
to the gulf stream and you can just
watch the water temperature popping up
we're gonna start trolling for mahi
wahoo
sailfish man we can hit all sorts of fun
things
gotta tell you something i really admire
about my son tommy here
he gets seasick on these open water
charters sometimes but he still loves
coming out on him
so what we're doing is we're trolling
with a little bait fish called a
ballyhoo
it looks like a little teeny tiny
swordfish each one of these ballyhoo is
rigged up beforehand
got the eyes out a little lead under the
gills
gotta tie it in there it's a little bit
fidgety so you get them all
tied up ready to go before you start the
day out
this one will just be popping across the
surface right this will be
just sub surface uh stay about 12 inches
below
he's hooking this rod up to the
outrigger and then using that little
pulley system to get the line out
further away from the boat so you can
fish more rods
without them getting tangled while you
troll also allows you to fish a bigger
swath of water
oh yeah he's like a little popper yeah
it's designed to
catch air in this little concave head
okay right now he's rigging up some
teasers
a whole bunch of these rubber squids and
they don't even have hooks on them the
point is just to look like a school of
bait fish
and tease the fish get them in to our
actual hooks and bait
when tommy was little i used to buy big
old teasers
as a reward for potty training so i had
a big bucket of little rubber
squid that was my bride
you feeling better tom good
all right guys we're here at the end of
may in north carolina
and that's a great time to catch big
mahi mahi or dolphin fish
and dolphin fish are notorious for
hanging out near any sort of floating
structure
around weed beds or buoys
or debris anything that holds bait fish
so we've jogged out here to the gulf
stream and we're looking for
weed beds or groups of weed that's
floating in the water
and we're trolling up and down those
weed beds looking for some big mahi but
we could also hit sailfish or wahoo
barracuda maybe a tuna anything could
happen
you can see little schools of bait fish
right there by the
weed now the one downside to fishing
near the weed is you get a lot of weeds
snagged up on your line
so you have to constantly jerk the line
try to clear out the weeds
we got flying fish right there
seeing lots of flying fish going off
that's a good sign
big patch of grass right there let's see
if there's anything underneath it
right here hold it up
they come though we got a good smack
from a mahi mahi right by that weed bed
so we're going to rebate turn around try
again
where there's one my there's often more
oh that's all that's left of our bait
i'm dumb we're all wrong tom come on
josh jumping he's jumping
oh there he is doubled up i just went i
saw him jump clean out of the water
buddy
what do you think tom that's your first
bodybuilding
beautiful all right there you go guys
that's the mahimahi right there my face
look at the beautiful colors on that
thing
i know
just don't jump
oh we got a good look at him he was big
and beautiful
but hey you know when they get away that
makes him even bigger
well you're out fishing your dad look at
you man
but i believe you can do it too dad
you feel a little better a lot better
some
everything's tommy's perking up eating
some breakfast
he's got the color back in his face
that's a nice grass patty right there
nice
i love yellowfin and another one yeah
right there
right there i see something silver
look at that pretty shark you got bro oh
look at that
that is so awesome tom kind of stark is
it
bar oh nice sandbar
yeah yeah yeah you like that are you
happy yeah
that's awesome all right let's get it
back in
that's cool slap my gopro on the way out
cheeky guy
yellowfin tuna my absolute favorite fish
to eat
glad to see you oh what a wonderful fish
all right uh yeah put them in there and
one bleeding
so what he's doing is bleeding the tuna
when you get the blood out of the fish
while it's still fresh it makes the meat
taste a little better makes the meat
preserve better
yeah your shark nibbled that up good
yeah tom are you having a good trip
all right guys i got the whisker seeker
catfish and carp series carbon fiber rod
here
and uh we're gonna see if we can't catch
some little mahi on it
it's gonna be fun we'll start chunking
like dealing feet on our squid
we got little pieces of squid we're
going to chum them out
we can get little mahi to rise to it
then we'll give them one with a hook
see if we can't catch a few all right
all these good guides work together as
teams
and jared's buddy over here has been
catching little mahi's
right by the boat so we're going to join
them
everyone right here oh i'm under here
oh there we go
oh
yeah there's just fish everywhere
this is crazy you can just see him
swarming down here
they're actually sight casting for mahi
this is awesome
oh he came right at it
oh
we're sitting here catching these mahi
maya we just saw a signal on the fish
finder means there's some trigger fish
down deep so we're gonna really quick
try to catch some of those too that
looks kind of like a heavy-duty sabiki
rig
yep kinda like a chicken rig all right
got an eight ounce lead
a little high low rig here we're gonna
see if we can't catch some trigger fish
yeah there's yeah you got him hold on
reel him in
here keep that right up
yeah whoa they fire aggressively
yes they do buddy
don't let go of my rod like you do the
rest for me i'll teach you
sure we'll see
small fish definitely
look at those teeth man those are wicked
wicked chompers
man look at that
that one yep
[Music]
nice
[Music]
beautiful fish and they fight so hard i
never would have expected it
well i don't know about it dear tom you
want to do it
oh yeah that's got good look at that
don't worry he can't get you like that
just go right under the bottom we are
doing the smorgasbord
trip here we are trying to catch as many
different species and experience
as many different things as we can and
tommy here
really really wants to catch a sailfish
so we're going to troll our way back
into shore a little bit
and if we have a little bit of time then
we'll try for some snap or two
a good hour
keep reeling real fast
keep going
oh it's good
all right guys we've done a bit of
trolling but we're going to switch gears
and try fishing for vermilion snapper
and some other bottom fish
oh my god follow me in job man pull over
oh yeah i'm coming a little
[Music]
oh i got a little double going on
something trying to eat that looks fresh
it is
hey thumb right there yes
oh he's got a grunt oh dead mouth grunt
another thought they call him red mouth
grunts see see the red mouth
it's beautiful yeah look at me a little
trigger
i have no idea wait wait oh i got
another orange oh
my god oh there you go oh yeah
you got one one snapper
daddy hold on your rod hold on
double double contact
there we go
oh a little something different here
yeah so this is a bank
bass a pretty i like my big bass
big big [ __ ] oh tommy we're out of time
man we gotta head back
so we gotta get back home and cook these
things up we got
a ton of fish to cook
look at all them fish in that box
throw it right next to mine all right
that's actually pretty comfy
i can't do
oh hey i thought you were done bleeding
come on 26 26 i knew that
like i was still at four and then you
got five i'll tell you what i had a
great time catching those mahi
and trigger fish on this little rod if
you guys want to know more about this or
you want to buy one i'll put a link down
in the video description where you can
get the whisker seeker catfishing carp
series rods
doing good doing good i thought are you
going to go swimming after
right yeah i'll tell you what guys
there's a lot of fillet knives on the
market
but every time i come and see one of
these guys flay fish they'll only use
two brands of fillet knives either a
dexter russell
or above a knife
[Music]
what's your favorite grab it there you
go
there you go you got it look at that
prettiest piece of me
stab it with it
that's for them i'm sorry this table
says slippery
they're trying to steal some me
it was like i'm out of here
there you go nice lovely piece of yellow
fin right there
need to be
all right let's get this in the car
darren we had an absolute blast thanks
for taking us listen if you guys are in
north carolina and you want to do a trip
like this
i'll put captain jared's information
with tombstone charter
down in the video description below make
sure to check that out i'm gonna go do
some
do some cooking yes sir thank you buddy
hey you have a great day
all right well now we got to drive six
hours to get home
take the next left onto atlantic beach
causeway
all right me and tommy made it back to
the house and now we have got a load of
fish to cook up you excited
yes so i've got a lot of recipes planned
i'm gonna do coconut crusted
mahi mahi with a mango reduction i'm
going to do seared tuna steak and then
i'm going to do
tuna tacos with a tropical fruit pico de
gallo
and avocado seared vermilion snapper and
i'm going to put them on a toasted
baguette with fresh mozzarella
basil and tomato but i've never eaten
trigger fish before so i'm going to try
cooking it with butter garlic and
rosemary
and then kind of see what happens
just let this sit and all the flavors
kind of mix
there we go
[Music]
uh i'm not bringing toys down though
cause i come down
you said five-ish
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay take a little baguette a salted
tomato there you go a little vermilion
snapper on a baguette
okay so this is trigger fish and it's
supposed to taste like fresh scallops
because i love scallops one of my
favorite seeds
crumbly no it's it definitely got the
scallop texture i haven't recorded that
mom
it's tuna steak time we gotta steer some
tuna steak now
[Music]
all right who's got a plate and an
appetite and that is
good to hear all right amy what do you
think it was amazing i loved it all of
it i couldn't pick a favorite well i
could
this i like this coconut thing you like
the coconut mango
it's amazing that's good thank you what
was your favorite
coconut mahi mahi mahi
yes snapper's good yeah oh i mean it's
all good
yeah trigger fish how do you like take a
fish okay
oh that was a lovely meal wasn't that
becca that was great it was all good and
i don't really like fish i liked all of
it
oh i like you thanks for watching guys
we hope you enjoyed that video as much
as we enjoyed eating that
fish but if you guys want to see more
great videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
saturday morning
nailed it nailed
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching